all right today in Pahrump The Ninth  Annual Balloon Festival cakes off at pet  rock park now it runs through Sunday  balloons start going up in the air at  seven o'clock every morning and  admission is free now there will be  music food vendors and of course a car  show on Saturday sounds like a lot of  fun there all right and the Las Vegas  pizza Festival announced it's coming  back and it's at the industrial event  space with some of the most talented  Pizza innovators in town including good  Pie Pizza Rock among others now it  starts tomorrow at noon and of course  for more information you can go to our  website 8newsnow.com